my book on the great reset I go into the
whole digital currency what they're
trying to do and they're actually done
it now in several countries that I think
it was Zimbabwe or and uh and obviously
Canada where they're you're going to be
government Joe Biden just did an
executive order about three months ago
about a central bank digital currency to
essentially compete with cryptocurrency
the idea here though is you're going to
be relying on this government your
credit card will be shut down your
banking will be shut down if you don't
get a coveted vaccine if you don't uh
support or fall out of favor with the
party and there's actually a partnership
now between the United Nations and
MasterCard called a dichotomy a credit
card where it's going to monitor your
carbon footprint and the car the world
economic forum is very excited about
this the card cuts off your spending
when you hit your carbon footprint Max
in other words if you get too much gas
or if you you know fly buy airline
tickets your card stopped working now
it's voluntary at the moment it's for
people who want to monitor it but how
long before that you know six months a
year before that becomes mandatory as
all part of it control your banking
control your thermostat this is about
human freedom and that's ultimately what
the climate battle is about and now the
real battle and the next transition of
this is going to be the viral battle in
this pandemic treaty I think is the
greatest threat I don't think they're
going to win though
I don't think they're going to win it's
a question of how many years of darkness
before they lose that's the question
Soviet Union didn't win but they had 70
years think about it think about think
about building one of the most
ridiculous Technologies of all time and
not wanting any credit for it what are
we talking about Bitcoin Bitcoin oh yeah
okay and I'm not even I'm not even a
Bitcoin guy I have some Bitcoin in
ethereum but I'm not the guy that's
going out there saying you know that's
if you but think about producing the
greatest one of the greatest
Technologies out there and not caring
for people to say who you are like think
about that even about Satoshi yeah yeah
whoever the Satoshi Nakamoto is right
think like you know how some people
write these books that's not their name
what do they call it there's a word for
it uh what is it called pseudonym right
and then eventually what comes out yeah
I wrote that book you know it was a
really me that wrote that book right
this guy still has not come out so how
do you process that here's how I process
that
for you to produce someone like that
where you create a revolution in the
world essentially because everybody
governments are by everybody's talking
about this Bitcoin thing
and you're sitting there imagine imagine
him on the you know you know sitting in
his living room and he's watching and
saying yeah
okay
you know what I should come out and tell
the world I build it I bet I'm gonna get
more girls I bet I'm gonna get more of
this but I'm going to get more respect
I'm gonna I should go out there and say
no I really don't give a [ __ ] that guy
who produced it is driven more by being
left alone than recognition yeah you you
can they're not gonna win you don't win
with there's people behind closed doors
who are just sitting around who are so
powerful and they don't even to impose
their power on you they don't care for
the recognition they don't give a [ __ ]
for you to tell them how special they
are those are the people that they're
waking up so for me I think Common Sense
prevails and I think they're waking up
the wrong people and those wrong people
are ones who know how to stand up to
them I hope I hope whoever isn't elon's
Erin is talking to him
you're also a man who's going to make up
his own mind he's going to do what he's
going to do
um I hope he realizes buying one of
these virtual governments is very very
important to not let all of those guys
be on the same page it's very important
for somebody who is reasonable in the
middle to own one of the big social
media companies it would be
revolutionary it would put a massive
dent in all their plans so so to the
point to the point where even if the
people who have money like this is the
part that you got to give credit to the
left and not the right the you know what
the left will do right say elamas was on
the left salamos was on the left and
they had to figure out a way to come
together and get that money to make sure
this still gets done or whatever it is
you know what they would do they'd be
doing zooms and calls and conference
calls to make sure everybody came
together and they'd be raising money for
each other to make sure they got that
money to make sure they own Twitter I
hope the people on the other side are
also making calls and doing whatever
they can to help this man end up owning
Twitter but at the same time you know
with what you're saying with Tesla the
fears I don't know man I hope he stands
up and he picks picks up Twitter because
somebody opposing From the Mob needs to
own one of the social media companies
someone needs to do it he's pretty much
the only one at this point because
they're so big and powerful it's uh but
but by the way let me let me tell you
what kind of very weird thing happened
in the last 24-48 hours kind of like the
fact that bezo kind of threw himself out
there maybe Bezos is sitting there
saying [ __ ] I'm not as love this musk is
yeah because I'm playing it so damn safe
you know what I'm the new Rebel and I'm
the new guy you know what screw this
[ __ ] of trying to be the Mr Nice Guy
worth 300 billion dollars and you know
what forget about it I'm in the game of
recreating myself I'm about to show you
guys what I'm really all about I'm gonna
push my weight as well I hope that
backbone comes out but you're just
hoping when that backbone comes up
people are not bought on the back end or
afraid of all these other fears that
people are going to bring so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]